Another kind of synchronization perimeters that is very
popular in multithread apparel programs, and extremely useful in
the developing applications, especially in the scientific domain,
is what is called a barrier synchronization. The idea
here is that, there are multiple threads and
they are doing some computation And they want to get
to a point where they want to know where everybody
else is at that, at that point of time.
And they want that insurance that everybody has reached a
particular point in the respective computations so that then they can
all go forward from, from this barrier to the next phase
of the computation. Now I'm sure that you've gone to dinner
with your friends and one of the experiences that you
may have had is that, and you may have a party
of four or five people that are going for dinner. Two
or three of you are showing up at the dinner restaurant.
And the usher say wait, you know, do you have the
entire members of your party here? If they're not here wait til
the other members of the party show up, so that I can
seat you all at the same time. And that's sort of the
same thing that's happening with barrier condition. It is possible that, you
know thread t1 and t2 arrive at the barrier, meaning they completed
their portion of the work. They've gotten to this barrier but the
other threads that are lagging behind and those shirkers are going to eventually
show up but they're not here yet and until
everybody shows up nobody can advance to the next
phase of the computation. So that's the idea, behind
barrier synchronization, exactly similar to the analogy that I
mentioned here. So we looked at two types of
synchronization primitives. One is the lock, and the other
is the barrier synchronization. Now, these are concepts I
am expecting that you know already. If you find that
these two concepts are either new to you, or you would Like some refresher for
that, I strongly advise you to go and, and take a look at the review
lesson that we have on multithreaded programming.
Now that we understand the basic synchronization primitives
that are needed for developing multithreaded applications
on a shared memory machine. It's time now
to look at how to implement them. But before we do that,
let's do a quiz to get you in the right frame of mind.